the huge International row that followed
China flying a spy balloon Over America
has deeply impacted relations the two
biggest Global economies are also the
two biggest competitors deeply baked
into that competition are security
concerns which is why unusually three
cabinet secretaries were called to brief
the U.S Senate on the perceived growing
threat from China
Beijing has increased its bullying and
provocations in the indo-pacific it's
embarked upon an historic military
buildup including in space and
cyberspace
of course war is neither imminent nor
inevitable
but we must face up to the prc's growing
assertiveness the Department's mission
is clear
to deter aggression that threatens our
Vital national interests China is
looking to expand its influence building
up ties with emerging economies around
the world particularly in the global
South it's also building his Industries
challenging the dominant position the US
has enjoyed for years the main areas of
competition Computing and the growing
emergence of artificial intelligence the
US has already banned sales of some
technology to China there's a battle two
in the supply of telecoms equipment and
in Aeronautics and Automotive sectors
China represents the most consequential
geopolitical challenge that we face
today a country with the intent and
increasingly the capability to challenge
our vision for a free open secure and
prosperous International order and it
has become a battle of development and
diplomacy we have never been more
aggressive in using our Department's
tools to address the threats from China
the seriousness of the perceived threat
from China is reflected in the fact that
all three cabinet secretaries talked
about a whole government approach to
compete and at a time when Washington is
obsessed with debt limits and talks of
spending cuts this was a high profile
pushback against the idea of non-defense
spending cuts using China's potential
dominance as a deterrent Alan Fisher Al
Jazeera on Capitol Hill in Washington